Вітаю.
Я Ольга Дудар.
Вчитель Києво-Печерського
ліцею № 171 "Лідер"
і викладач Київського
університету імені Бориса Грінченка
Ми з Вами помандруємо в
героїчне минуле українських земель
і дізнаємось більше про видатного
діяча Данила Романовича – князя
і, в майбутньому, короля.
Але, перш ніж ми розпочнемо
роботу з новим матеріалом,
давайте спробуємо пригадати
важливі події, які вивчили напередодні.
Отже, пригадайте, будь ласка,
яка подія відбулась у 1199 році?
Який процес тривав із 1205 по 1238 роки?
Що відбувалося в тодішніх
українських землях з 1237 до 1242 року?
Поміркували?
Це дуже важливі події,
які насправді змінили життя
Галицько-Волинських земель.
Отже, в 1199 році
Роман Мстиславович об`єднав Галицькі
і Волинські землі в одне князівство.
Проте, після його трагічної загибелі,
його сини Данило і Василько тривалий
час боролися за батьківську спадщину,
і це відбувалося протягом 1205-1238 років.
І остання дата, яку я називала - це
другий похід монголів на Руські землі.
Якраз Данило Романович,
наш сьогоднішній з Вами герой,
відчув всю важкість нападу,
всю важкість походу на собі.
І я пропоную вам сьогодні пригадати
по нашому матеріалу дуже важливе вміння -
вміння складати історичний
портрет видатного діяча.
Я пропоную вам сьогодні повторити
такий дуже цікавий спосіб роботи,
як складання історичного портрету
видатного діяча чи персоналії.
Давайте з вами пригадаємо,
як складається цей план.
Це не обов`язкові його
частинки. Це мої рекомендації.
Але я все-таки раджу
вам звернути на них увагу.
Отже, перше нас цікавить:
як зростала ця людина,
яким було дитинство, де вона вчилась,
яку освіту отримала, що
вплинуло на її формування?
Друге – це особисті
якості й риси характеру.
Яким цю людину, або якою,
запам`ятали сучасники, можливо -
якою вона описала себе сама.
Третє, дуже важливе питання,
це - що здійснила персоналія,
які реформи, досягнення, або навпаки,
які труднощі зустрічалися на її шляху.
І останнє – це враження сучасників,
можливо, це характеристики вчених,
а, можливо, це Ваше ставлення до діяча.
Але хочу наголосити,
зверніть увагу на те,
що коли ви висловлюєте своє ставлення,
обов`язково треба його аргументувати.
Використайте якусь подію,
використайте якусь цитату з історичного
джерела, але поясність своє ставлення.
Це для історичного портрету дуже важливо.
Отже, почнемо наш історичний портрет.
Що ми знаємо про Данила Романовича?
На жаль для нього,
в 1205 році трагічно
молодим загинув його батько.
Данилові, як старшому з двох
братів, було близько трьох років,
молодшому брату
Васильку - десь до двох років.
І уявіть, двоє маленьких
хлопчиків залишилися з мамою.
І, це моє враження,
судячи з характеристик в літописі,
судячи з висновків істориків -
Данило Романович був схожим на
свого батька, але зростав без нього.
І це, звичайно, дуже вплинуло
на формування особистості князя.
Ще один дуже важливий момент - мама.
Княгиня Анна була
непересічною особистістю,
оскільки не скорилася обставинам і вела
тривалу боротьбу за інтереси своїх синів.
Що ми знаємо про неї з літописів?
Вона не хотіла підкорюватися
дуже сильним і своєнравним
Галицьким боярам,
проблеми з якими були і у її
чоловіка Романа Мстиславовича,
і, в майбутньому, у двох її синів.
І навіть коли вона на їхню вимогу
залишала Галич, залишала своїх синів,
вона однаково не складала руки.
І певна доля успіху
князів Данила і Василька -
це звичайно наполегливість
і віра їхньої матері.
Тому, от саме політика
матері, теж, напевно, доволі
значний вплив здійснила на юного княжича.
Ще теж хочу звернути
вашу увагу на таку деталь.
З певних причин
Данило Романович тривалий час
провів при дворі угорського
короля Андраша ІІ (або Андрія ІІ).
Він жив там один.
Ні літописи, ні угорські хроніки
не повідомляють нам про те,
що у князя був хоча б вихователь
з його звичного середовища.
Маленький хлопчик,
десь близько шести років,
виховувався абсолютно не
знайомими йому на початку людьми.
І це, напевно, вплинуло на його характер.
Але ці роки не були для нього
лише трагічними, лише важкими
з дуже прагматичних причин.
Саме при дворі угорського короля,
юний Князевич отримав гарну
освіту, навчився вправно їздити верхи,
навчився фехтувати і багато
дізнався про внутрішні
політичні інтриги, зв`язки, ситуацію
між західно-європейськими правителями.
І тому він був гарно обізнаний, знав
про багатьох, знав важливі моменти
і гарно орієнтувався в зовнішній політиці.
Тобто, оцей негативний досвід життя в
Угорщині - він мав як важке враження,
так і важкий вплив на характер майбутнього
князя, так і певні позитивні риси.
Тепер давайте звернімося до
нашого дуже важливого джерела -
до Галицько-Волинського літопису,
де повідомляється, що, насправді,
йому було важко морально,
тому, що після розлуки з матір`ю, коли
він побачив її вперше - він її не впізнав.
Уявіть собі, не впізнав
рідну маму і заплакав.
Через деякий час,
коли Галицькі бояри вирішили
залишити маленького князя
у себе, а матір вигнати для того,
щоб вона не мала на нього впливу і від
його імені, можливо, здійснювати політику,
Данило Романович знову плаче через те, що
мама, з якою він тільки що возз’єднався,
вимушена його покинути.
І я думаю, що цей момент,
коли він розумів, як
люди інші впливають на родинне життя,
теж його зміцнив.
Тому що в майбутньому ми з вами зрозуміємо
– Данило Романович мав дуже гарну чесноту,
він не опускав руки з-за важких обставин.
Мені хотілося аби всі ми формували
в собі таку рису - вірити в себе.
І які б перепони не
траплялися на нашому шляху,
у нас завжди є достатньо сил всередині
і у нас завжди є близькі люди для
того, щоб підтримати нас і розвивати.
Ще одна людина, яка
стовідсотково підтримувала князя
і в майбутньому короля – це
його молодший брат Василько.
Ми знаємо про це з його практичних справ.
І я сьогодні згадаю ще про ці моменти.
Але його дуже гарно
охарактеризував літописець.
текст на екрані
Я сподіваюсь, що ви пам`ятаєте
- хто такий цар Соломон.
Поміркуйте, в 6 класі
ви 100% читали про його
діяльність, і зараз у всіх людей,
хто цікавиться давньою історією,
хто прослухав шкільний курс,
цар Соломон асоціюється з мудрістю.
Так от, літописець недарма
порівнює князя Данила з Соломоном,
через те, що які б, дійсно,
складні обставини не були,
Данило Романович зумів пересилити їх
і дійсно змінити життя
Галицько-Волинської держави.
Тому ця характеристика
надзвичайно влучна.
З іншого боку я закликаю вас
не ідеалізувати жодного історичного діяча.
Звичайно, що в літописі, який писався
за часів наступників Данила Романовича,
його ідеалізують, створюють йому
надзвичайно привабливий образ.
В житті він не міг бути янголом -
він був князем, від якого залежало
і безпека кордонів, і економічний
розвиток його князівства,
і протистояння з ворогами,
а іноді протистояння
внутрішньо-боярської опозиції.
Данило Романович був рішучий,
іноді жорстокий, іноді агресивний,
але це ні в якому разі не
применшує його досягнень.
Що він отримав,
коли почав боротися
за батьківську спадщину?
Він і його брат мали протистояти великій
кількості загроз – це і галицькі бояри.
Я думаю, що ви пам`ятаєте, як про них
говорив Роман Мстиславович, батько Данила,
що не вбивши бджіл – не поласуєш медом.
Якщо ти хочеш мати сильну державу,
треба долати боярську опозицію,
оскільки проблем від неї було чимало.
Далі Ігоревичі – сіверські князі.
Місцеве боярство хотіло
запросити їх і підтримувало,
сподіваючись, що ці князі будуть слабшими,
і не зможуть проводити таку політику,
яку владно здійснював Роман Мстиславович,
яку мали б здійснювати його нащадки.
Далі – це сусіди,
поляки і угорці, які втручалися в
боротьбу нащадків князя Романа.
Це хрестоносці, які починають спроби
ближче і ближче підсовуватись до кордону
і захоплювати якийсь вплив.
Ну і найважче для двох молодих князів,
звичайно, було протистояти
монгольській навалі.
В 1215 році – це рік першого
успіху Данила і Василька.
Вони закріпились на
Волині, в князівстві їх батька.
В 1230 році вони об`єднали
всі волинські землі і вже звідти
вели боротьбу за Галицьке князівство.
І врешті-решт у 1238 році Данило Романович
об`єднав всю батьківську спадщину.
Причому жителі тогочасної
Галицької землі розділилися.
Бояри в жодному разі
не хотіли сильного князя,
але місцеві люди, прості
(ремісники, купці, селяни) розуміли, що
сильний князь – це шанс на
захід від злісних і свавільних бояр.
І тому, коли Данило Романович прийшов
у Галич, він спитав у місцевих жителів:
«Жителі міста, доки ви хочете
терпіти владу іноземних князів?».
І жителі з радістю відповіли, що
це ти наш володар, Богом даний.
Оскільки вони сподівались на
його більш мудру і прагматичну
політику щодо Галицького князівства.
В 1238 відбувається ще
одна дуже важлива подія.
Зверніть, будь ласка, на ілюстрацію.
Разом із своїм братом,
Данило Романович
зупинив наступ хрестоносців
і вигнав їх з міста Дорогочин.
І його слова: «Не гоже держати нашу
землю крижевникам-хрестоносцям»
якраз демонструють
розуміння, що це загроза.
І якщо її зупинити своєчасно,
показати силу і рішучість,
у того, ймовірно, в майбутньому
цих проблем буде все-таки менше.
Успіхи князя Данила
були затьмарені набагато
складнішими подіями.
Давайте пригадаємо, що він
учасник першої битви з монголами.
Я сподіваюсь, що ви засвоїли
– це битва на річці Калка.
Данило Романович зазнав там поранення
і він зрозумів силу нового ворога.
Коли монголи в 1240 році захопили Київ,
а Київ теж, давайте пригадаємо,
був сферою впливу князя Данила,
і Київ захищав його воєвода Дмитро.
Після цього монголи
з Києва ідуть на захід.
І це для них було дуже важливо.
Монголи готувалися до другого походу.
І вони знали, що Данило
Романович сильний князь.
Вони зустрілися з його військами,
коли брали в облогу і здобували Київ.
І тому вони знали,
що міста сучасної західної
України так просто не здадуться,
і розуміли, що їм важливо не допустити
об`єднання князя Данила з сусідами,
тому вони швидко рухаються на захід.
Данило теж розумів всю небезпеку.
І він намагався умовити сусідів
об`єднатися і виступити єдиним фронтом.
Це дуже складне завдання,
оскільки тоді поляки, угорці,
не розуміли, або не хотіли
об`єднуватись з політичних міркувань.
І врешті-решт всі зазнавали поразок від
доволі сильного монгольського війська.
Я думаю, що монголи дуже швидко досягли
земель Галицько-Волинського князівства
ще з міркувань того,
аби не застати там князя
і швидко захопити під
контроль ці території.
В літописі йдеться так: «І почув
Бату о Данилі, що в Уграх є»
і тому князь не міг керувати захистом
своїх земель від монгольської навали.
Монголи не прагнули
повного знищення і повної
дестабілізації ситуації в князівстві.
В них був інший інтерес – брати данину.
Тому руйнація була,
руйнація була масштабною,
але відродити і економічне
життя, в тому числі, шанс існував.
Тепер давайте звернем увагу на
той момент, який, можливо, не дуже
детально описаний в підручниках –
це битва під Ярославом.
Це остання спроба опозиції
родичів частини угорців
разом подолати князя Данила.
В цьому бою князь, який вже не
дуже юний, якому вже за 40 років,
а в ті часи це доволі суттєвий вік,
показав себе і як
стратег, і як рішучий воїн.
Коли він дізнався, що вороги
розташувалися і взяли в облогу Ярослав,
він разом із своїм сином Левом,
разом із своїм воєводою
Андрієм і братом Васильком
рушив на ворога і розділив свої війська.
Він з сином пішов по центру,
зверніть, будь ласка, на це увагу,
а Андрій і Василько були на флангах.
Коли Данило Романович
побачив угорське військо,
яке не дуже до нього ставилося
позитивно, а потім Флоріана,
можливо, у нього була особиста неприязнь.
Але сталось те, що Данило
Романович вирвався вперед
і вступив в реальний бій з ворогом.
Він не просто керував військами,
а він ледве не потрапив у полон.
І тут на допомогу князеві
прийшов його син Лев.
Лев так вдарив свого
ворога, що зламав свого списа.
Врешті-решт вони
перемогли, зламали прапори
і це стало такою деморалізацією
для решти ворожого війська,
що вони втратили запал
до боротьби і почали тікати.
Данило разом зі своїми воїнами
ще цілу ніч гнався за ворогами,
хоча для нього це було фізично небезпечно.
І в цьому бою, як свідчать історики,
показали себе з найкращого боку
всі керівники війська Данила Романовича
- і його молодший брат, і його
син Лев, і його воєвода Андрій.
В принципі, ця подія засвідчила, що
князь зміг, навіть в таких тяжких умовах,
створити реально сильну і
дуже дисципліновану армію.
Проте, цей успіх був затьмарений.
Адже за князем
спостерігали хани
і в 1245 році
Данило отримує вказівку – дай Галич.
На що він відповідає: «Ні. Я не
здам міста, а поїду до Батия сам».
Це було небезпечним,
адже всі князі знали долю Чернігівського
князя, страченого за те, що він
не захотів продемонструвати
свою повагу до хана.
Літописець описує ці події з
певним трагізмом і говорить, що
«лихіша лиха честь татарська».
Але Данило Романович зумів хитрістю,
зумів дипломатизмом добитися ярлика.
Ярлик – це право на княжіння,
яке хан давав тому князеві, який
визнавав зветність, сплачував данину,
а ще гірше - надавав свої
війська за розпорядженням хана.
Проте на 1245 рік Данило Романович зміг
знайти певний баланс із монголами.
І це дало можливість йому
провести дуже важливі зміни.
Князь активно захищав економіку.
увага на екран
Теж хочу вам нагадати, що
Галицьке князівство багате на сіль,
і прибутки солі давали
можливість князю теж
витрачати кошти на дуже важливі справи.
Це будівництво укріплень,
і я думаю, що якщо ви відвідували славне
місто Львів, то ви знаєте його історію.
Данило Романович заклав це місто
на честь свого сина і соратника Лева.
Дуже важливою для
князівства була реформа в армії.
Військова реформа -
краще будемо говорити так.
Що зробив князь Данило?
Він посилив роль народного
ополчення і фінансував військо.
От якраз прибутки із солі, які
отримував князь, він спрямував на те, щоб
воїн і дружина отримували
достатньо коштів.
Його військо складалося з двох частин
це важкоозброєні воїни,
вони основна наступальна сила
і стрільці, які атакували, нападали,
наносили шкоду противнику.
Таким чином
велика роль піхоти і її укріплення на той
час - це було доволі прогресивне рішення,
яке дозволило князеві власне
військо підсилити
і таким чином дійсно мати
більш безпечне середовище.
Щодо зовнішньої політики.
Князь боровся з агресією з
півночі, з північного заходу –
це ятвяги та литовці,
провадив шлюбну дипломатію,
одружував своїх синів з представницями
правлячих родин Західної Європи
і найважливішим для нього було
створити антимонгольську коаліцію.
Він використовував різні аргументи.
Говорив, що європейці ходять в хрестові
походи на територію,
яка не потребує захисту,
а сусідні народи і шлюбні
зв`язки потерпають від монголів,
тому краще було спільними
зусиллями створити військо, і цю загрозу,
це поневолення економічне, і
цей військовий примус відкинути,
врешті-решт і з руських земель.
В надії він звертається до Папи Римського.
І Данило Романович розумів, що Папа - це
сильний моральний і релігійний авторитет
і сподівався, що з його допомогою
він таки організує цю коаліцію.
Але у Папи Римського були інші плани,
він завдяки Данилу Романовичу
напевно що хотів поширити католицизм.
Як би там не було,
але в 1253 році в місті Дорогочин
представники Папи Римського
коронували князя Данила.
І від тепер його треба називати королем.
Це перший король в
сучасних українських землях.
Але
для нього ця подія не була
настільки радісною, як можна очікувати.
Для Данила Романовича важливішим
було створити союз проти Золотої Орди.
А мета не була досягнута.
І, по-перше, вік.
Він, як учасник багатьох боїв і
людина, яка зазнавала поранень,
уже мав проблеми зі здоров`ям.
Він розумів, що в силу
політичних обставин,
не всі його плани
можуть бути реалізовані.
І, насправді, як він себе почував
в той момент ми не знаємо.
Але в пам`яті у нащадків король
Данило залишився як мужній воїн,
як мудрий політичний
діяч і як певний взірець.
Тому я пропоную вам,
на основі моєї розповіді,
скласти свій історичний портрет.
Але звертати увагу не лише на факти,
а й звертати увагу на емоційну складову.
Адже кожний видатний
українець: чи то політик,
чи то діяч культури,
чи це герой баталій – це жива людина.
І нам з вами дуже важливо зрозуміти для
себе, що ці живі люди створюють історію
і історію творимо й ми з вами.
Дякую Вам за увагу!
Я чую, що вже дзвенить
дзвоник і нам час прощатись.
Успіхів вам!